yo
so what's some some of your favorite
house of hit memories for people who
don't know
hip boy had a crib in tarzana everyone
lived there
we had a crib everybody had a creature
let's be clear man because uh
you know we we we we had brad go into
that crib man no that [ __ ] was crazy
it was just the environment the creative
environment of that [ __ ] was wild
yeah we had a um we did have the the
[ __ ] biggest and the dopest i'll say
not biggest but i'll say
dopest compound
and had easily the biggest parties in la
them years that we were doing it like
without a doubt like for sure
that's what was some of my favorite
moments other than like your boy just
coming downstairs and
telling me hey [ __ ] man
now it's gonna be here in an hour just
wild [ __ ] like that throw me away you
know what i mean until like make sure
you tell me like don't
don't invite nobody make sure don't
nobody pull up because
this wild ass person is coming you know
what i'm saying and only
i can luckily be in there and this
person that you know [ __ ] likes that
like her boy is [ __ ]
that's my [ __ ] like that's dude
that's nigga's god did you guys ever
record on some [ __ ]
and then he ended up having to break it
to y'all like hey guys sorry rihanna
took this one
or hey guys sorry oh man that's a
beyonce
listen watch the i mean [ __ ] in paris
was a whole another
the homie had a whole different song
chili chill had a whole different song
to that like we always
that would always happen let me think of
a [ __ ] song um
i don't know but that would always
happen you know or
just [ __ ] man it would be sometimes
songs i can't really think of it because
it would be like all we did was create
so sometimes we would set the platform
for certain records that like [ __ ]
sometimes we would get take off songs
but we wouldn't give a [ __ ] we were
it was it was to benefit the game so
it's like [ __ ] if the [ __ ] getting
placed or
whatever we was just creating you know
so um i can't even remember it was so
many [ __ ] moments but my favorite
moments though
i gotta say was like our parties because
i remember like literally like i would
be
standing we had this wild-ass balcony
where where the dj would be dj and i'd
be on the mic
like hit boy be up there like like i got
a wild ass picture with me
hit boy frank ocean james fondleroy
travis scott
whoever else the [ __ ] is on that balcony
from way over there travis got [ __ ]
low-ass hair
yeah you know when travis was opening up
for casey veggies when frank ocean was
coming to [ __ ] parties
like you can't get frank ocean to go to
coachella right now
you know what year was that uh probably
like 2013
you know sometime around there um but
just like the people we will be watching
like
big sean walking up about us the game
[ __ ] chris brown like all these
[ __ ] were just in our front yard you
know what i mean
at the party we wasn't even inviting
people half the time
[ __ ] just had to be there because we
was having the craziest parties
the whole ie slide and that's what was
making the parties this [ __ ] because we
was bringing the ie
you feel me that was bringing a
different everybody drive out different
energy
more more interested in having fun
ghetto
yeah turn [ __ ] was turned [ __ ] was
doing a wild problem doing
while [ __ ] the party axe problem next
time if you ever do whatever then you do
a problem
ask him the netty ass that his netty ass
moments at the crib he was my favorite
person coming
oh your problem used to be crazy amazing
i remember doing to a problem the
problem is uh
yeah he's a fun guy he parties i mean
listen welcome to mollywood
you know what i'm saying that was that
all you gotta do is just [ __ ] you
know
listed album just listen to the album